we're going to begin this hour with an
inside look at that acclaimed comedy
series I know you know it The Marvelous
Mrs maisel the fifth and final season of
the Emmy and Golden Globe winning show
premieres April 14th on Prime video
that's coming up we will finally learn
what happens to Miriam Midge maisel the
mid 20th century New York housewife
turned stand-up comic found herself at a
crucial Crossroads at the end of last
season you remember that is a cast of
this beloved series rap filming and said
their goodbyes they invited Anthony as
in Mason to join him on the set first on
CBS mornings we're in Brooklyn now and
then we walk through this door and we're
in the Upper West Side of Manhattan
that's right this is the set welcome to
my humble abode
I have apartment envies so do I honestly
a visit to Midge maisel's apartment is a
trip back in time to early 1960s New
York
these candies may or may not have been
here since the first season I was
wondering about that yeah would you like
to try one that's okay thank you for
offering in the final days of filming
Rachel brosna has oh thank you who plays
Midge maisel and Alex Borstein that's
4050 for you and 450 for me who plays
her manager Susie Meyerson this is our
living room gave us a tour of the set
that would soon be struck does it feel
real to you in its own way it does after
so many years where the hell are we what
is this Versailles my apartment your
table is set for 30. who has Cutlery for
30. I know this apartment almost as well
as I know my own that woman last night
she was not me Brosnahan was 26 when she
won the part of The Marvelous Mrs maisel
it was a breakout role Olympus goes in
that mouth before you leave to see young
man playing a divorced Jewish mother who
becomes a stand-up comment my life's
completely fell apart today
said you couldn't do comedy yeah well
obviously prove them wrong I don't know
depends on who you ask
am I supposed to find them intimidating
because because all I see is a lineup of
men who had to go into comedy just to
get laid
together Midge and Susie take on the
male dominated world of Comedy okay
let's pick some big time comments across
all five boroughs I'm making some calls
tonight your relationship is obviously
critical to the show Rose knew this was
kind of the central Romance of the show
yeah the romance she's had a marriage
fail but Susie remains and mid remains
it's it to me it feels like the most
important yeah love story
another important love story this is the
neighborhood this is our name this is
the nasal neighborhood midge's parents
Abe and Rose Weissman played by Tony
Shalhoub and Marin Hinkle we were
worried Miriam worried sick if you must
know your mother vomited I did not vomit
well she did something in the bathroom
that took a very long time and she did
not come out looking happy we shot the
pilot in this real apartment they
reunited recently after filming it ended
outside the building used for the
exteriors of the maisel apartment and
here we are home here it is I wish you
miss it
yeah incredibly yeah yes we even missed
the set that set was the most beautiful
home I'd ever had and as we finished I
actually said could you lock me up in it
and they they didn't they didn't let me
no I asked them to lock you up in it
Shirley's coming in she might be naked
she walks around the house naked
you two have one of my all-time favorite
TV relationships oh thanks there's
nobody I would rather be working with in
the world than this person and there
wasn't one moment of tension in all
those years unless you're not telling me
was there something that you felt no
there was we literally delighted in the
possibility of what we've got to do
every single day the show has taken Abe
and Rose from Manhattan to Paris to a
summer in the Catskills ladies welcome
back to Steiner Mountain Resort your
home away from home I want to know what
your reaction was when you got the
script that had the Catskills
calisthenics scene in it
I my reaction was I need to go on a diet
touchdown every morning 10 times and you
were in a romper correct yeah a romper a
one-piece a darling Romper did you get
up there that day and just sort of like
improv yeah and I just making up these
ridiculous
ten times it was kind of liberating and
you know what I mean I just I felt very
I felt very courageous the climactic
scene last season took place in Carnegie
Hall where Midge goes to watch her
friend Lenny Bruce perform
[Applause]
what was it like to shoot in Carnegie
Hall well I mean you can imagine yes
Luke Kirby plays a fictional version of
the real life comic you as Lenny end up
being kind of a grounding Force for her
and a North star
yeah they have a really tender beautiful
friendship there's a kind of honesty
that they're able to have because
they're not committed to each other in
any way they're just committed
to the same craft I hear you turn down
the Benedict
yeah
I did when Midge turns down a shot at
opening for Tony Bennett Lenny lays into
her don't you want this
don't you want to be here he has no
other responsibility to her but to be
totally honest if you blow this Midge I
swear
that's why that moment is so powerful
yeah yeah well hopefully she listens to
him
it's showtime
soon learn how the story ends but the
actors have already said their goodbyes
how's that feeling
it's not terrible
kind of bitter right now I think we're
just all aware that we're breathing
rarified air when we're here and you
know and we're gonna miss it we're gonna
miss each other I wish I could still do
it you do yeah I'd never wanted to leave
the character she was the most
delightful and the people that we got to
be did you feel that way when we
finished
it's heart-wrenching to not be in the
world so thank you for bringing us back
here today
[Music]
with Abe and Rose we took one last
stroll through the maisel neighborhood I
don't want it to end yeah
they all they all come to an end that's
the problem
yeah that is the problem that was such a
wonderful cast and you can tell how you
can see how much they really love each
other yeah um they also all love that
set like if anybody who watches that
show has a pasta apartment envy and
costume you know it's really exciting
yeah they'll close I was looking writing
is amazing so many admirable Parts about
it yeah they make the actual comedy in
the show the stand-up funny yeah it
could work on its own for the time frame
that it's in yeah but even get it I mean
that's hard to do yeah it's like making
the music good in a show about a band
but you know it's sort of weird it
breaks my heart when I was sitting on
that set and I thought you know in a few
weeks this will be gone they'll take it
down and it's like because it's so real
to me I could have I posted a picture on
Instagram I could have sat there all
afternoon just served me a bourbon I
would have been there all afternoon
Anthony I want midge's yellow dress that
you just said please get it for me in a
size 10. I want Anthony Mason's giant
blue umbrella
though in all the different locations
how long did it take you to do this we
started shooting that when they were
shooting their final scenes in October
November yeah wow awesome job it's gonna
be missed that show all right Anthony
thank you very much